en un examen de opción múltiple la
pregunta 1 tiene cuatro opciones cuatro
opciones y la pregunta dos tiene tres
opciones cada pregunta sólo tiene una
respuesta correcta cuál es la
probabilidad de contestar ambas
preguntas bien si se elige la respuesta
de modo aleatorio
así que adivinando cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener la respuesta
correcta en ambas y lo primero que
tenemos que notar y déjenme lo escribo
es que elegir una respuesta en cada
pregunta son eventos independientes es
decir la probabilidad de estar bien bien
en la pregunta 1 estar bien en la
pregunta 1
y la probabilidad de estar bien
en la pregunta 2
son eventos independientes
eventos
y dependientes y recuerden eventos
independientes son aquellos que no
tienen ninguna influencia entre ellos
elegir aleatoriamente la respuesta en la
primera pregunta y elegir la bien no
afecta para nada elegir aleatoriamente
la respuesta en la segunda pregunta y
elegir la bien son cosas que no tienen
influencia entre ellas entonces nosotros
sabemos que la probabilidad de que ambas
cosas sucedan como son eventos
independientes es el producto la
probabilidad de estar bien
en la pregunta 1 y simultáneamente estar
bien en la pregunta 2 es igual al
producto
de las probabilidades de estar bien
la pregunta 1 viene en la pregunta 1 x
la probabilidad de estar bien bien
la pregunta 2
ok entonces cuántos eventos posibles
tengo en la pregunta 1 pues tengo cuatro
opciones para responder la pregunta que
tengo cuatro opciones y de esas sólo una
es correcta solo tiene una respuesta
correcta así que la probabilidad de
estar bien en la primera pregunta
eligiendo aleatoriamente es de un cuarto
si multiplico esto con la probabilidad
de estar bien en la segunda cuál es esa
probabilidad pues ahora tengo tres
opciones y de nuevo solo una correcta
así que tres opciones y una correcta eso
me daría la probabilidad de estar bien
en ambas y esta probabilidad sería un
cuarto por un tercio que es un 12 a 1
entre 12 veamos esto de un modo gráfico
déjenme hacer una pequeña tablita donde
pongo que nos puede pasar en la pregunta
pregunta número 1 y también pongo lo que
nos puede pasar en la pregunta
pregunta número 2
qué nos puede pasar en la pregunta
número uno pues hay cuatro opciones tres
de las cuales son incorrectas y solo una
es correcta así que tengo la primera
respuesta incorrecta la segunda
respuesta incorrecta la tercera
respuesta incorrecta y finalmente la
respuesta correcta quizás no aparezcan
en este orden o en el examen pero no
importa
qué nos puede pasar en la pregunta
número 2 pues ahora tengo tres opciones
de las cuales sólo una es correcta así
que tengo la primera respuesta
incorrecta luego tengo la segunda
respuesta incorrecta y finalmente tengo
la respuesta correcta así que si hago
una tablita aquí
supongo mis celdas
y me va a quedar muy fea está tabla pero
bueno
o algo así
cada celda lo que representa es una
opción por ejemplo podría elegir la
primera respuesta incorrecta en la
pregunta 1 y la primera respuesta
incorrecta en la pregunta 2 y eso me
llevaría a esta celda también podría por
ejemplo estar viendo la primera pregunta
pero elegir la segunda respuesta
incorrecta en la pregunta 2 así que
estaría en esta celda de todas estas
celdas cuales satisfacen mis condiciones
pues en realidad solo estoy aquí es la
única en la que estoy correcto en la
segunda pregunta y correcto en la
primera pregunta así que
solo tengo un caso favorable entre
cuantos casos pues tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 opciones posibles así que la
probabilidad de estar bien en ambas
preguntas de nuevo nos sale como un
doceavo otro modo de obtener este 12 es
simplemente notar que tengo cuatro
opciones para la primera pregunta y tres
opciones para la segunda pregunta de
modo que 3 por 4 también es 12 así que
ambos métodos nos llevan a la misma
solución